ce fut un exploit tonitruant que celui
réalisé par le docteur alain bombard en
1952 quand il traversa l'atlantique en
solitaire et sans provision à bord d'un
canot pneumatique justement baptisé
l'hérétique lombard n'était ni assure un
avenir sportif simplement un
scientifique attaché au musée
océanographique de monaco et qui prouve
est inimaginable que les victimes de
naufrage disparaissent alors qu'à ses
yeux la survie était possible aussi
choisit-il de démontrer par lui même la
justesse de ses convictions il trouva
alors les mécènes
on ne disait pas encore les sponsors
d'une expédition transatlantique perçu
par les gens de mer et de médecine comme
une folie pure
les morts du titanic à ses yeux avaient
été victimes du froid et de la panique
or celles ci sont jugule et la mer est
riche d'éléments qui précisément doivent
permettre la survie cette expérience il
l'a raconté dans un ouvrage étonnant de
simplicité et d'héroïsme naufragés
volontaires que les éditions phébus ont
la bonne idée de rééditer enfin de
tanger à la barbade
on va on le sait s'est nourrit de
plancton ces micro éléments végétaux et
animaux en suspension dans l'eau de mer
et il a bu l'eau douce contenue dans les
poissons il a regardé les étoiles et les
images où il a réussi